téléphone dans ta vie tu as vécu
énormément de choses oui et c'est vrai
que ça fait 20 ans que tu es sur m6 mais
tu as eu une grande carrière avant aussi
je vais te proposer de jouer avec tous
nos chroniqueurs à une photo un souvenir
ça concerne à chaque fois dans l'écran
vont apparaître des photos
à toi de me dire à quoi le fonds pense
agir aucune accord regarde premières
photos regardez la photo
alors oui les teams bravo tu tires
ardisson nikos aliagas oui quoi je dis
nation alors avant d'être animateur
j'étais petit chef à france 2 eh ouais
et donc on a embauché thierry ardisson
et christine bravo et on a casté à tout
jeune chroniqueur nico qui était nikos
et donc j'ai été son chef
ah ouais là dans 99
et donc voilà et j'étais donc j'étais en
régie là et je disais justement faut
dire abus d'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé sur des singes des petits chérèque
christine bravo lui a dit vous a dit hu
donc un charisme tu ne seras quand je
lui dis je vais faire dans tel elle m'a
dit mettez complètement fou tu vas te
planter mais elle manoeuvre est un jeu
n'a pas vraiment on a donc aucune chance
mais n'a aucune chance aucune chance ah
ouais pas mal
il m'a dit fonce vas-y c'est flou voilà
exactement téléspectateurs allaient les
loups ont écouté quelques jours celui
qui a fait l'unanimité la semaine
dernière avec l'annotation catholique
c'est bien sûr john rachid et mais
toujours des mecs je le tiens bien
nikos mon loulou tombera sous il l'a pas
pas
[Rires]
les photos suivantes
ah oui c'est vrai que j'ai fait la
première grande interview de céline pour
la télévision française après la mort de
rené c'était un grand doc en prime sur
m6 c'est ça produit par frank sera et
donc c'est très particulier parce que
une fois que tu as rencontré non je
l'avais déjà vu pour à une variété au
jeu que j'avais animé et ensuite on a
fait j'ai fait de variété en prime pour
m6 avec elle mais pour moi dès que je
pense à ça je pense je pense à ce moment
là parce que tu es dans ses petits
souliers quand même hein parce que tu
fais la première interview avec
l'amérique la france et québec est
spécial femmes je sais battu chez moi
bien je sais et voilà donc et pour le
coup elle est actuellement facile
d'accès c'est étonnant c'est la plus
grande star du monde evan j'adore ça
c'est un beau jour elle m'a appelé et
m'a dit s'il suffisait qu'on s'aime
[Musique]
c'est en tout cas ce étonnant c'est
quand ils arrivent quelque part elle
attend jamais qu'une porte s'ouvre quand
l'ascenseur s'ouvrent donc tout est prêt
sur son parcours c'est vrai c'est assez
incroyable contre 6 devait faire ici ça
va avec la régulière je voudrais que des
portes avant qu'elles arrivent pour
l'interview il y avait il y avait des
gars postés à chaque porte un regard
postés à chaque ascenseur séoul veut que
l'ascenseur elle est passée à d'or à ses
formes à samassa sas a célébré ça allait
les cherry qui regardent photo / photo
suivant laquelle m alors c'est moi
j'suis pas du tout sur les réseaux
sociaux j'ai un compte instagram que ma
fille ce cher parce que moi je suis nul
en revanche j'ai fait une médiation
commence à arriver
c'est numérique j'étais avec beckham
pour une émission et il m'a demandé de
faire un truc c'est pas faire dame
exactement fallait qu'on revoit ce dab
pour les tunisiens qui nous regardent
c'est un dab c'est un grand club
envoyez un truc à la mode en ce moment
s'appelle le dab
je tape le dab c'est une danse avec les
mains c'est juste un geste fait comme ça
avec bach m
on y va on s'arrête pas là
[Applaudissements]
pour sa collègue sa collègue
il se raconte pas oui mais il sait pas
trop si ça peut se faire
c'est comme si on peut le relancer ça tu
peux le relancer ça donne aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane regarde une photo ou encore la
grèce un autre truc car gallas et merci
regardez regardez ça serve à ça alors
c'est pas moi c'est pas celle là oui
c'est une fourmi de fusil ouais ouais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors la
partie limitée du fournil fusil je vous
dis c'est que l attaque récit mêle vous
vous piquent et lorsqu'elle vous piquent
l'adulent la douleur c'est l'équivalent
de ce que vous ressentiriez si vous
prenez une balle de fusil a insisté que
ça dure 24 heures ceux-là c'est une
grosse thalasso et moi j'ai eu la chance
j'ai été piqué par une formule fusil
mais à travers la chemise ce qui fait la
douleur était moins forte c'est pas vrai
ça mais c'est un soin de vous mais tu
l'as pas dit lâche ton fusil la vidéo
mais il ya une vidéo
mais une vidéo non mes sources actuelles
je croyais pas je ne vais pas regarder
cette photo je les pâtes les parties n'a
pas été retouchée nos photos s
voilà bah ça c'est sa fille paris là on
a eu très peur pour toi alors ça c'est
vieux maintenant c'est arrivé le 12 son
accident toutes les images les héros est
encore classé vrai métier que ça fait
flipper et c'est plus alors ce qui est
impressionnant c'est que j'ai le micro
sur moi et du coup en attendant la stone
se froisser ses statuts pris un crash en
tout mais et du cerac d'avoir le micro
dans un an tant de bruit de tôle
froissée
donc c'est assez impression mais moins
impressionnant à vivre en vrai que avant
les images rien
[Musique]
au moment où le side-car à freiner pour
une raison totalement incompréhensible
il a fait une embardée
on s'est occupé de lui on a commencé à
le sortir de là il y avait du sang sur
le visage sur les bras et vêtements
déchirés mais il était conscient et
quand même globalement beaucoup de sens
parce qu'il aura pu
être beaucoup beaucoup plus grièvement
blessé c'est pas grand chose à l'arrivée
[Musique]
dans la gueule mais pas moi je voyais la
colombie et mon frère ouais alors le oui
alors c'est vrai que ça faisait donc
susic aller ça dans la vie dure c'est
fait c'est fait rien et était plutôt
beau gosse comme ça rien j'arrêterai
boire est un des plus beaux gars des
animateurs je le connais j'ai eu la
chance de doigts retenue